Last time we looked at how
to apply our new ideas.
I've perfect equilibrium
to a whole bunch of games.
And our general idea for how to solve
for subgame perfect equilibrium was as
follows.
We looked at each sub game we solve for
the Nash Equilibrium in the sub game.
That's something we learned to do long
ago. And then we rolled back the payoffs,
we rolled them back up the tree and
towards the end we learned something
interesting. I don't know, I'm not
going to go back to [inaudible].
That's one to emphasize it.
We learned that strategic effects matter.
So in that investment game we looked
at last time when you were considering
whether to rent a new piece of machinery,
it made a very big difference
whether you considered how, uh,
how this action would affect the
actions of the other side. In this case,
how it affects your competition.
And this is a very general idea.
Very general point. So just, just to
give you a couple of more examples.
When you're designing tax systems,
I mentioned this last time,
when you're designing a tech system,
make some changes in the U s tax system.
It's not good enough to look at how
people are behaving and the old tax system
and just calculating
and accounting manner,
how much more money you're going to raise.
Well,
how much money it's going to cost you.
You have to take into account how that's
going to lead to changes in behavior.
And once again,
that's a strategic effects.
And in the homework that
you're handing in today, uh,
all of you would have had it nice example
of that in the toll booth problem.
So in the toll booth problem,
when you're putting tolls on roads or
more generally when you're building new
roads, new bridges, new flyovers,
new bypassed is you need to take
into account how those new tolls,
how there's new roads will
affect all of traffic flow,
traffic flow down the tree. We'll, we'll,
we'll form a new equilibrium and you need
to, you need to consider that in, in, uh,
in designing your told in designing
your road system. All right?
So that's another example of sp.
So today I want to do thing
quite different a little
bit like what we did with
dual.
I want to play a game today and probably
spend the whole of today analyzing this
one game. So it's quite a complicated
game, but it's been a fun game. All right,
so what's the game we're going to look at?
The game is going to involve two players,
okay?
Right in each,
each play out in each period,
each period
they shoes each chooses,
I should say,
each chooses,
he chooses whether to fight or to quit.
All right? So ask me in his fights and
Q means quit and they make this choice
simultaneously. All right,
I'm the game and this,
the game ends as soon as someone quits,
as soon as someone quits all tell,
there's good news and bad news for this,
for this game.
Let's do the good news first.
The good news is
Vat.
If the other player quits first,
if the other player quit first,
you win a prize,
you win a prize.
And generally will call this Prize v
but we'll play for it for some cash in a
minute.
The bad news is,
okay,
the bad news is each period
in which
both fights,
sorry,
in which both players choose to fight
each player.
Hey,
he's a cost,
so they paid minus c.
All right,
and just to keep things interesting,
let's fill in the other thing here
would cheese if both credit ones.
So it's both quit at once,
then they get zero that period.
All right,
so this is a game we've
seen a little bit before.
We start a little bit under
the auspices of Hawk dove,
those people in the Mba class
sort of game a lot like this.
But we're going to analyze this in much
more detail than we did before as we can
from the whole of today talking about it.
So to start this out,
let's actually play this game. All right?
So I want to volunteers. Uh, let me just,
uh, since this is a football,
see college football season,
let me see if I can
play off the rivalries.
So don't have anybody here
from the great state of Texas.
Whole Bunch of texts is all right. All
right. What does keep your hands are on a,
using a second and uh,
I guess the rivalry here is Oklahoma.
Anybody from Oklahoma?
Okay.
Mirror Oklahomans are,
what we'll do is we'll pull,
pick two texts and then we'll just
assume this is Texas and Texas a and m.
All right. So texted them, trace
their hands again. All right,
we're going to pick out to Texas.
All right.
And uh, I'm going to give you a
mic each. Uh, so your name is nick.
Nick,
why don't you keep hold of them or you
can just point it towards you when you
speak, but still shout because
we know the rest of the,
everyone here wants to hear
you. All right, so this is nick.
What was my other texts and back?
Yeah,
I just want to hear when they go for
the poster one. All right. That's okay.
We'll start here. And your name
is Alec. Alec. So started at Alec.
That's better. Okay. All right,
so the game is this. All right,
they're going to have to write down for
the first period whether they choose a
fight or quit.
Oh,
with each player will have a
referee for the person behind Alec,
it's going to be Alex referee
to make sure that, uh, the, uh,
that Adec is actually saying
what he says he's going to do.
And what happened to my other texts,
him, I've lost my Alexa there is,
and your name again was nick and nick is
going to write down fight or all quit.
And uh, to make this real, let's play for
some real cash. So we'll make the prize.
Why don't we make the
prize equal to a dollar
and the costs equaled a 75 cents.
All right, so I've got some dollars
to, here we go. This is a, uh,
what did you call this in, in Texas?
We called this a fistful of dollars.
Is that right? Does that mean all
right? So, okay, so where am I playing?
Right when you stand out you guys
so everyone can see you.
All right. All right. Can I made this
difficult night? No, no, no, no, no.
You're going to write down your strategy.
So we'd have to go grab a pen.
And what I did,
I didn't make that easy for you.
Let me come down and make it easier for
the camera person. All right. All right,
so, so, uh, what did you, uh,
write down what your strategy is going
to be and tell your neighbor what it's
going to be?
I want to see what happened.
All right. Show you. Show you a referee.
Have you found your referee? All right.
And, uh, again, nick speaking into the
microphone, what did you do? A quit.
He quit. I quit as well. So
much for the [inaudible]. What?
I'm going to remember the Alamo.
I mean this is all right.
So Texas didn't work very
well. Okay, fine. Let's try it.
Let's try a different state.
I have to say it. My, uh,
my wife's from Texas and my wife's
family is from Texas. And I had them had,
I thought they had more
fight in them than that.
Maybe that's why they're sliding in the
polls. Let's try somebody from Ohio.
Anyone from Ohio?
Nobody from Ohio and the whole class.
That's no good. That's
like, I'm going to pick,
I'm going to pick a higher against
Michigan. How about some people from some,
from some of our own teams.
So are there any players on the football
team other than the other than the two
I picked on before? There we go now
and got something. Here we go. So, uh,
oh, I need a different team.
Anybody from the hockey team?
Anybody from the baseball team. Ah,
okay, good, good, good. All right. So,
uh, a friend from the baseball
team, I get, uh, your name
is Chris, Chris and our,
our new football team player
is Rollin Rollin Rollin.
Okay.
So Ryan and Andy and Chris are going to
play this or seeing the need and easy
use nearly as from Texas.
I take it all right,
so we have some hope or something
happening here. All right. So, uh, uh,
write down what it, what it is you're
gonna do. You're gonna have to choose.
Yeah.
All right. Has both written something
down? Yeah. All right. And uh, Ryan,
what did you choose? Fight and Chris, I'm
going to quit. Oh, well that was easy too.
Okay. Okay. So the football team looking
pretty good here. All right. All right,
so we're getting not getting much in
the way of, uh, of action going here.
Anyone else want to try here?
Another little state rivalry here?
I don't suppose I've got
anyone from Oregon that's
asking too much. I went from,
you guys must be from somewhere.
It's gotta be,
it's gotta be a state where at least one
of you is prom. All right. All right,
well let's try something like New
Jersey. How about that? Alright,
so it doesn't play as from New Jersey.
That's good. All right. All right.
There we go. So, all right. And we'll
try New Jersey in New York, that seems,
but that seems like there's a bit of
a rivalry that you're from New York.
Excellent. Here we go. Here we go. So,
and your name is Kiersten and your name
is Andy. Andy. Okay. So guessing and,
and these are show up. They'll send up.
Someone comes to you on it. Let's see if,
uh, if there's any fight in,
in New York and New Jersey.
All right. All right. Okay.
So write down your strategies.
All right, good. Now, so, all right. So,
uh, uh, Andy, the, what did you choose?
I'm going to fight. Fight. Ah, here
we go. This is better now. Hey,
worried there for a time. I know, I
know it's there. The thanksgiving,
what the has to be some sort of spark
left in the class. That's okay. All right,
so we have,
we have both people facing,
which means right now they're down 75
cents, but the prize is the dollar.
So the game goes on. So write down again
what you're going to do second period.
Okay.
All right. The 75 cents is gone. So now
we're just looking at the game for dollar.
All right. And let's, let's go to New
York. What does New York, I'm gonna fight.
Fight. Fight. Okay. So this is, you have
to stay on the east coast to get life.
There's no point of going away. It's just
that, that's not that. That makes sense.
All right, so, so write down
again what you're going to do.
Okay.
Okay. And let's go though
around a New Jersey fight.
Fight, fight again. All right,
so right now we're down with three
75 cents, whatever that is. And uh,
it's a still this prize of a dollar out
that plus perhaps a bit of pride here.
All right,
so write down again.
All right, let's try again. Let's go with
the York. This time I'm going to fight,
fight, fight. Okay. I'm guessing,
I'm guessing we could keep this going
for quite a while. Is that right?
I'm going to think he's a good
thing for quite a while now.
It might make a difference by the way,
if there are to talk to each other here.
So let's see if it does.
Okay,
so let's allow New Jersey and
New York to talk to each other.
You can't insult each other about
bridges and tunnels. Just regular Salk.
All right? So, uh, anything
you want to say to your friend
from New Jersey here? I,
I can't let New Jersey when
it's just the New York pride.
You guys are just every weekend,
every round. So I'm sorry. All right,
well I'm going to keep fighting your
best choices to give up. All right.
Let's see if that works.
I see that we're getting out of that.
So choose the strategies again.
Yeah.
York, I just can't let Jersey women fight.
Bring it on. Fight. All right. All right.
So it's clear that we kept this going
for awhile. It would pay for my lunch.
Is that right? Is that right? All
right, well we'll, we'll, we'll,
we'll hold it here a second. We'll
talk about it a bit, but thank you.
A round of applause for our team.
Feisty, feisty, Fyi.
All
right, so what's doing on
here? So clearly we can carry,
we can see what can happen in this game.
You can get people quitting early.
All right. And, uh, uh,
it could be that one side is quit and the
other side doesn't equate that towards
something can happen that
can happen pretty quickly,
but it's possible and
we just saw it happen.
It's possible that a fight could
go on quite a while. All right?
A fight could go on quite a
while here. All right. Now why,
what's going on here is
this, I mean, the prize,
the prize here was what was a
dog and the cost was 75 cents.
All right?
I could have raised the stakes maybe on
these guys and says that that meant that
made a difference. But you know, I think,
I think a dollar and 79
something my hands we'll do.
And by the time they'd
fought the second time,
they exhausted the possible pry pries
of a dollar. Is that right? Right.
So it's true that if you won
this in the first period,
then that's fine because you
just got a dog and he wouldn't,
he wouldn't have cost you anything.
And even if you want in the second period,
you'd be okay.
You know he cost himself 75 cents
for fighting in the first period,
but you know you're getting a dollar.
So that's good,
but their arm and they're all
went on for plenty of time.
In this case they're on, you're just
accumulating losses. So what's going on?
So it, there are various
conclusions possible here.
One is that people from New York and
New Jersey are crazy, right? That's a,
that's a possible thing.
All right,
but what else could we w w why
do we get involved in this fight?
What happened here? Why do we tend
to see fights like this emerging?
I containing this isn't touch
an implausible situation.
Why don't we see the motor hits?
Let's talk to our friend from New York.
Shout out. By the time she fought
with me on the second round,
I knew I was going to be losing money
anyway. So why not just keep going?
All right. There was no reason
I wasn't going to win anyway.
Somebody said just keep
fighting so she quit.
All right. All right, so there's,
I think there's two things.
There's two parts that answer.
All right.
Part of the answer is I'm going to be,
I'm sorry I have lost of money
anyway. Right? It's hold that piece,
that piece of it, and the other part
of it is what the other part of it is,
I really determined to win this
thing. All right. All right,
so there's two things going on
there and they're quite different.
Let's take the second one first.
It's possible that the reason these
fights emerge and can go on for quite a
while is that even though the
prize is only a dollar in honey,
it could be that the actual thing
that the players care about is, well,
what are the players
actually care about here?
Somebody just raise your
hand or put you on the mic.
What do people tend to care about
in these situations? Winning.
They care about winning or they care
about pride. Is that right? It's not.
Know that,
that's why I started with Texas,
but I couldn't find any pride in Texas,
so we had to go to New York. Right?
All right, so people care about,
people care about winning per se.
It's a pride thing. All right. So
it could be that a dollar simply,
isn't it a good description
of the true payoffs here?
It could be that the payoffs are
actually about winning. All right?
It also be that both of these guys know
that they're going to be interacting
with you at other times in the
class or other times at Yale,
and they want to establish a reputation,
both of them as being the kind of guys
who fight, right? In particular when they,
when they got to talk about it, right?
Both of them said, look, I'm a fight.
Since I was nothing we've seen before
with ally and his peace and his a pizza
shop, both of them said, I am a fighter.
You bet it back out. Is that right?
To both of them tried to signal the facts
that they were going to fight to try
and get the other side to quiz? All
right? So that's about reputation.
And that reputation could
extend beyond this game.
It could be that they're going to
be involved in this kind of, uh,
conflicts later on in life. All right?
So both of those things are around.
All right?
Uh,
there's another element to this and that's
the other part of what are our friend
from New York said,
which is about the costs.
What's true about the costs in this
game as we move from period to period?
What's true? If somebody said
it, say it again. Say it loudly.
It's a sunk cost.
All right?
So all of those costs that you
accumulate as the game goes on there.
Irrelevance.
Looking forward because they're sunk.
The fact I've played this game for 10
periods and hence lost 10 10 times 75
cents, which even I can
do that. Seven 50 right?
The height I've lost 750 is irrelevant
because I've lost it anyway.
I can't get that back.
That's a sunk cost.
So the game 10 periods through looks
exactly the same as the game did at the
beginning when fighting seemed
a good option. That right?
Alright,
he's a 10 periods through the game.
You have the same view about
facing as you did at the beginning.
Now that's not quite true because at some
point you're going to run out of money.
All right? But do we ignore that?
Basically those sunk costs are irrelevant.
All right,
so what we're seeing here is reasons why
people fights and some of these reasons
seem to be substandard economic
reasons like sunk costs,
and some of them seem to be about
things that are outside the game,
like pride or possibly reputation,
right?
And it's certainly the case that in the
real world we do see fights like this,
or is it, let's just spell out
what the key feature of this is.
The key feature of this is in
these fights over a period of time,
even though you may only be losing a
little piece in each period over a period
of time, you could lose a lot. In fact,
you could lose far more than the prize
that was originally at stake, right?
It's all right. So, so the, the, the,
the lowest is you could accumulate and
that our friend from New Jersey and New
York,
but Los isn't the accumulated vastly
outweighed the prayers that was at stake
after a while. All right. That's,
that's a worry. That's a worry. Right?
Okay. So this, this is gonna occur in
real life, not just in the classroom.
What do we call these kind of fight
these fights where that's that they're
holding out for this possibly small
prize and incurring, possibly small,
but they're humid into being
large costs each period.
What do we call those fights?
Okay?
Nobody,
well,
let's think about some examples if see
if they would come side of examples.
So one example, let's do
some examples. He yet,
one example is, uh, what
happened in World War One?
All right. Two in Walmart as a,
I'm assuming most of you know, uh,
the, uh, on the, uh, on the western
front at least the, uh, the, the,
uh,
German and allied and an to Germany armies
faced off with the British and French
and allied armies for an extraordinary
long time fighting over extraordinarily
small patches of land, little pieces
of northern France and Belgium.
All right? And you could argue that these
pieces of northern France and Belgium,
I didn't wish to offend anyone
in French [inaudible] here,
but you could argue that those few
acres of northern France and Germany,
one worth a whole lot. Anyway.
All right? Nevertheless,
the troops are the two sides kept on
fighting for our firm from what 1914 to
1918 and enormous losses of wife
were accumulated over that period.
All right? So that, that was a
really costly longterm battle.
Neither side would quotes each year,
huge numbers of lives were lost.
If you doubt that,
go and look at the memorial and Yale
that shows how many Yale American lives
were lost and America was only in
that war for about a year. All right?
Okay, so that's an example. Another
example, and more a business example.
An example we talked about in our MBA
class, but not in this class so far,
is uh,
examples in business where
there's a market and that
market is really only going
to hold one from, all right? Well, that
markets are you going to hold one firm?
You can end up with an extremely long
fights about who's going to end up being
the one from in that market,
right? So a famous example,
actually it's a famous business
school case, is the fight
that, uh, that incurred,
uh, to control satellite
broadcasting, uh, in Europe.
So there was a fight between Sky
television and the British Satellite
Broadcasting Company,
uh,
that went on for a number of years and
these companies were doing things like
charging zero prices and giving away
satellite dishes and this, that,
and the other.
And over the course of the fights,
they accumulated so many losses that
it would, if you did the accounting,
the entire future projected profit flow
of winning this fight vastly outweighed
the amount of money that they'd
lost during the fight. All right?
That was a fight that involve on one side,
Rupert Murdoch.
And you could argue maybe Rupert Murdoch
is a little crazy and had a reputation
to keep up, but still it looks
like another example of this.
So that example was British
satellite broadcasting
versus sky.
So with those two examples there,
and they won't think of a general term,
we call these fights.
What do people refer to it?
How do people refer to the,
the method of fighting and well,
the one or for that matter during
the American civil war. Yeah.
Somebody in the back, shout it out.
It's a war of attrition. All right,
so these are wars of attrition.
Yeah.
These are wars of attrition and what
we know about wars of attrition is that
they can go on a long time and a lot
can be lost. A lot of life can be lost.
In the case of real wars,
I don't know if money can be lost in
the case of business wars. All right.
And actually it turns out a lot of
games have this structure of a war of
attrition.
Let me give you one more example.
Suppose that two companies
are competing for a market,
not in the manner of BCI be a of BSB and
sky basically advertising or whatever,
but in the form of paying bribes. All
right, so I suppose there's a company,
let's say in France and a company,
let's say in Britain,
and these two companies are
trying to control a try.
I tried to win a contract in some
country where paying bribes is a,
is a successful strategy.
And here I'm going to be careful about
the film and not mentioning the real
country. So let's call this
imaginary country free Donia,
which comes from a Marx brothers film.
All right? So here's this French company,
this British company,
and they both want this contract to
build a bridge in Fredonia and they start
playing bribes to the general who
controls for Donia. All right?
And what happens when you're not going
to get the bride back? So both sides,
no pay a few thousand
dollars to this general.
And then the general comes back and say,
what are you both pay the thousand dollars
which of you wants to pay the bridge?
So they'd go on and they put more money
in and more money in. And you can see,
once again, this is a war of attrition.
There's Brian was that they've paid,
they're never getting back.
But once you've paid them,
there are some costs, right?
Once you pay that bribe, good luck
saying, I paid you this bribe.
You didn't let me build the bridge.
Give me my money back right there.
It doesn't the caught in the world
that's going to enforce that. All right?
So these bribery contests
look a lot like this,
or there's a technical name for these
bright contests. They're sometimes called,
Ooh, pay auctions. All right, so
what do we want to establish today? We
want to establish, uh, what to talk about,
why you fighting occurs here.
And we wanted to do so in some details.
So there maybe in his formal reasons why
fighting a, and we've talked about that.
It could be that one side is crazy.
It could be the both sides are crazy.
It could be that national
or regional is at stake.
All of these things could
affect why we get fighting.
But what I want to try and establish
today is that you can get long fights
emerging in what?
Potential wars of attrition,
even if everybody is rational,
even if the payoff is just that $1.
All right? And even if there's
no reputation at stake. So again,
my goal today is to try and convince
you that you can get huge loss
of life and world war one,
a huge loss of money in these business
contexts without having to argue
something outside the model, like a
rationality or reputation. Alright?
Even rational players can get themselves
in trouble in wars of attrition,
right?
So that for the rest of the day,
I want to try and analyze this and
to get us started, I want to look,
I had a version of this game
at a simplified version,
which only lasts for two periods.
All right?
So we'll do a two period version
of the game we played just now
and eventually by the end of today, I want
to look at the infinite version. Okay?
So we'll start, we'll start
small. We'll start with a two
to pray,
right?
The trick and analyzing these things is
to be able to come up with a tree and
the other come up with payoffs and apply
the analysis that we know about to get
us to where we want to
be. All right? So here's,
here's the game I claim I claim,
but it has the following tree.
So first of all,
player a chooses and play.
An hey can either fight or quit.
And then we put a one in brackets,
we'll see what the one is in a second,
then play it.
Then we got a mobile player too.
But of course this is a simultaneous move
game and he just hung on hangers move.
So this is an information set.
I'm not going to play a
tournament player B to play a.
B doesn't know what a has done that
first period when B is making her choice.
This is the simultaneous move
and B is choosing between,
between, uh, fighting or quitting.
And just to distinguish them,
let me use small letters for B for B.
So once again,
fight or quit
and fight or corns.
All right,
now if both sides fights,
then the game continues and everyone
knows that both sides of sport at that
stage.
So at this point on,
we're actually at a singleton information
node and it's player a turn. Again.
Thank you. Thank you.
Sorry. All right. Thank you.
All right. So here we go again. So
in the second period, once again,
we've got a choosing
whether to fight or critic.
And this time we'll put it to to indicate
where in the second period and after
player to his moves. Once again, uh,
well off to a has moved. Once again,
play a B is moving up to simultaneous
move. And once again that choosing
Fido question,
I'll put twos to indicate that
we're in the second stage.
All right? So that's the structure
of this two Ed gain. Okay.
And let's write down what the payoffs are.
Starting with the easy pay offs.
So if both people quit in the first stage,
they get nothing.
If a quits and be fights than a gets
nothing and be gets V if a fights and be
quits,
then a gets V and B gets nothing.
And if they both fight, we go
into, we go into the second stage.
So it's right down the payoffs and
the second stage. So the second stage,
if they both quit on the second stage,
then their payoffs are going to be for
any minus c the cost they accumulated in
the first stage plus zero and for
B and for B minus c plus Sarah,
if they,
if a quit and be fights in the second
stage than the payoffs are minus c plus
zero and minus C plus B.
If a fights and be quits,
then the payoffs are minus
C plus B minus c plus zero.
And if they both fight for two periods,
we have a decision to make.
But how we're going to end the game
and this two periods in the super game.
But let's just assume that what we'll
get here is minus c minus c minus C minus
C.
Right?
What are some of they both fights the
game ends and no one gets the prize or
just to make it just to make life simple.
Alright,
so this is a to period to period version
of the game and the only change I've
made other making it two periods
is I have to put on a pay off.
That's what happens if the game didn't
resolve and I've assumed as the game
didn't resolve, no one wants,
no one got the price. All right.
Now there's another assumption I'm going
to have to make before we analyze this.
There are two possible
cases to consider here.
There's the case where the is
bigger than C, which is the case.
We just played it in the class and there's
also the converse case when the cost
is bigger than v.
All right,
so today we'll focus on
the case the bigger than C,
which is the case. We've
just, we just played in class.
I'm going to leave you to
analyze the other case,
the case when the cost is bigger than
the prize as a homework assignment.
All right? All right, so v bigger than
c is the, is uh, is our assumption.
All right? Is everyone okay
with the tree or this tree,
I hope describes the game? Uh, at
least a two period version of the game.
Now,
the first thing I want to point out here
is if we look at the payoffs that are
incurred at the end of
the second period game,
we noticed that they
all contain a minus C.
All right? There's a minus c everywhere,
all right? What is that minus c?
It's the cost that you accumulated
from having fought in the first stage,
all right? But the observation I want
to make straight away is that this cost,
so here it is. Here it is.
Here it is. Here it is.
Here it is. Here it is, and
here it is. And here it is.
This cost is sunk.
Hi,
there's these objects here are sunk costs.
There's nothing you can do once you're
in the second period of the game to get
these sunk costs back. They've
just gone there, there,
but the fact that they enter everywhere
is going to make them strategically
irrelevant. All right? Okay,
so what I want to do here is we want
to find all of the subgame perfect
equilibria of this level game.
All right?
So let me push this up quite high.
We'll see
and let me get rid of the rules.
We all know the rules by now.
So our goal here is to
use our solution concepts,
which is subgame perfect equilibrium
to try and analyze this gate.
So how are we going to,
how are we going to analyze this gay man
in terms of subgame perfect equilibria.
How are we going to start that discussion
when I got a lot of work to do here?
Where are we going to start and
finding so perfect equilibrium.
What's the first thing we should do?
When I came,
the first thing we should do is just
figure out what the sub games are.
Let's start with that. All right,
so having just pushed it far away,
I'm going to need to use the
pointer, but I claim that the, the,
the obvious sub game to it to
analyze first is this sub game.
It's the sub game.
If you should end up in period two,
I noticed that he's a sub game.
It starts from a singleton node.
It doesn't break up any information set
and it contains all of the descendants
of the mode from which it starts crying.
That is genuinely messed start again.
All right,
so we're going to start our analysis
by considering the second sub game.
Okay,
the second slot game.
All right,
so let's write down the
matrix that corresponds to
that second sub game and I'm
going to write it down
in the following way.
So I claim in this second sub game,
each plan has two choices.
They can fight well quits fights,
oh wait. And I'm going to write
the payoffs in a particular way.
I'm going to write the payoffs
as minus c plus this thing.
All right? So rather than keep that in
mind to see in all the which one to get,
it's going to get boring after awhile.
I'm going to pull that minus c out and
just put it in front. Is that okay? Right.
We had this,
we had this sunk cost box everywhere
and I'm going to pull out this sunk cost
box and put it in front of here it is.
If you get into the second period
of the game, if you've incurred this
sunk cost, all right? And
your payoffs in this game,
if you both fight,
then you incur minus
c for the second time.
If a fights and be quits,
then a is going to win the prize.
So they'll get the,
and a player two will get nothing.
If I, if I be gets nothing,
if be fights and ache,
which then conversely a gets nothing
and play a bee gets the prize.
And if they both quit, they
just get nothing, right?
She just knows what I did here.
I could've written out in the box with
minus c minus C here minus c minus c
here, minus c Plus v here, minus C
plus zero here, minus c Pissarro here,
et cetera.
But I just pulled out that minus c
because it's just distracting everything.
All right? So I pull out that minor
seed and put it in the front. All right?
Okay. So now we can analyze this,
uh, this little, this little game.
And let's start off by talking about
pure strategy equilibrate in this game.
So again, our goal is to find
subgame perfect equilibria.
So the way in which we find some gaming
equilibria is what we start at the last
sub games.
We look for Nash Equilibria in those
last sub games and then eventually we're
going to roll those back. All right,
so there's our lost I've gained,
there's the matrix for it lets us find
the, it's fine, the Nash equilibrium.
So if player B,
player B is fighting,
then pay it [inaudible]
best response is to quit.
And if Perrier is fighting, then play a
bes best responses to quit. Conversely,
if pay a be as quitting player A's best
responses to fight and if B is fighting,
play a [inaudible] a is quitting,
then play a bes best responses to
fight it didn't say that right?
Let me try it again. So if a is fighting,
uh, if the other side is fighting,
you want to quit. If the other side
is quitting, you want to fight right?
That clip. All right. So
there are actually two,
there are two to be careful here.
Your strategy,
there are two pure strategy,
Nash Equilibria
in this odd game.
And what are they?
They are fight,
quit and quit
fight. So if we get into the second
some game and if we're gonna,
if we know we're going to play up your
strategy and the second sub game and this
is what's going to happen,
that's our claim.
All right? All right. I
noticed that it didn't matter.
The Sun cost doesn't matter that I
could have included the sunk cost in the
payoffs, but I had to find exactly
the same thing with or without,
with or without the
sunk cost. So as, as we,
as we expect this one cost is irrelevant.
All right,
so we've gone, we've got both
the equilibrate and the son game.
Let's roll this back.
Let's roll these back into
the first stage of the game.
All right,
well I do that.
The payoffs associated with these,
the payoffs associated with this one
Oh v and zero and the payoff associated
with this one is zero and v one okay,
well that,
okay,
let's revisit the first stage of this game
and now things get a little
bit more complicated.
It's what I'm going gonna do is I'm going
to redraw the first stage of this game.
So Harrison,
there it is.
Hey Ken,
fight walkways,
justice before and following this
beacon.
Phyto just as before.
Well, this is a picture of
the first stage of the game,
but I'm going to chop off
the second stage. All right,
that's what the payoffs in.
All right. What? So the payoffs down here,
the same as they were before. Xero, Xero,
rocking up zero V if
a fights and be quick,
then it's v zero but what about
the payoff if they both fights?
So what I want to do now is I want to get
the pail for them when they both fight
by considering what they would get if
they both fight in the second period of
the game. All right, Mariah
idea is our idea is fine.
The Nash Equilibrium in the
second period of the game,
I'm rollback these possible payoffs.
All right,
so here the payoffs are
going to B minus C plus
stage two.
Yeah,
Nash Equilibrium.
Hey offs
the player one and minus
c plus the same thing.
Stage two
Nash equilibrium payoffs
for play B. All right, just
understand what I've written here.
Then I got the same pay office before
but I've replaced can reach it back.
I've replaced that enormous thing.
That was the second stage of the game.
Just with the payoffs that we know that
we're going to get in the second stage
of the game if we play Nash equilibrium
on the second stage. All right,
so these objects,
these objects have a name and the name is
continuation pals.
These objects are the continuation power
for the pals I'm going to get tomorrow
and possibly forward in a more complicated
case if in this case if I fight,
if we both fight in the first period.
All right?
Now what want to do is we want to draw
up the matrix that corresponds to this
first stage game and we're going to have
to do is to twice we're going to have
to do so once for the case where the
continuation payoffs are v zero whether
equilibrium we're playing tomorrow is
fight grid and we're going to have to do
so again for the case where
the continuation pay off
tomorrow are Zero v namely
the continuation payoff. The continuation
play is quit fight. All right,
I'll do it twice. All right, so let me,
you've got this to do
Asian power ups downs.
I convinced them to give us a
little bit of rum. All right,
so the matrix is going to look as follows.
Nice big matrix.
Do you buy to play an a is
choosing fights or quit the play?
A two is choosing phyto
quits and how much is easy?
It's what we put in here that matters.
So let's do all the easy cases first.
So quit.
Quit is zero zero quit fights is zero.
V Fight.
Quit is v zero.
And in here it's going to
depend which of these two games,
which of these two equilibria
is being played tomorrow.
So that we're going to do
here is where they do the case
for the equilibrium
fight.
Quit
in Stage two.
All right. When we gonna write
it in the Matrix for the case,
we're going to pay fight quit tomorrow.
So if we play fight,
okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you. And try
and keep, it's a good idea.
Try and keep you consistent today cause
it's very easy to slip. So that's good.
So once again,
I'm going to use capital letters for play.
A and small us will play a
beat. Thank you. All right,
so what happens if we both fight?
We both incur costs of c from fighting
and tomorrow we're going to get the pay
offs from the equilibrium
fights equates that to
this equal equilibrium.
So we're going to get v zero tomorrow.
That's add those in.
So this will be plus V
and this'll be plus zero.
All right.
And this has put some short crown here
to indicate that these are going to be
continuation payoffs, right? So this
is what they get. This is what the are.
This is the matrix going to use to
analyze the first age of the game.
In the case where the equilibrium
we're playing tomorrow is fight quit.
And as they promised me,
if you do this twice.
So the other case of course is if
the only other equilibrium tomorrow,
so it's just do that.
So once again,
we have fight one quit one fight,
one quit one and the payoffs are
same as we had zero zero's viz there.
And then here this time we're going to
have minus C plus zero and minus c plus
v. And the reason for the change is that
we're now looking at the continuation
game,
the continuation play
words player, what his player,
Hey, who quits in the second stage.
This is for the case,
quick to fight too
in period two.
All right,
so let's just pause, make sure
everyone's got that down one. Okay.
So what we've done here is we started off
by analyzing what's going to happen in
period two and that really
wasn't very hard. Is that right?
That was a pretty simple game to analyze
it. Pretty easy to find the equilibrium.
Then what we did was we rolled back the
equilibrium payoffs from period two,
and we plunked them on
top of the relevant. Uh,
I taught on top of the relevant payoffs
in period one. So in particular,
if you both fight and you know
you're going to play the fight,
quit equilibrium tomorrow,
then you'll pay.
Payoffs will be minus C plus
V and minus C plus zero.
If you both fight and you know you're
going to play the quit fights equilibrium
tomorrow, then you'll pay offs
will be c plus zero minus D,
Pissarro and minus c plus v.
And just to emphasize,
once again,
these four boxes we created,
correspond to the stage
to Nash equilibrium pay.
So the continuation payoffs of the gate.
All right?
Okay, so now we're ready to analyze
each of these games. All right,
so this isn't going to be too hard.
All right,
let's try and find out the Nash of this
game. So it's not with the left hand one.
This is the case where a player a is
going to fight and win in period two.
Alright, so if player, if player, uh, B,
if plan B is going to quit in
period one then if payer a fights,
she gets a v if she quits,
she gets zero.
So she's going to want to fight,
never.
Okay with that.
And if player B fights in period two,
then if pat [inaudible] fights,
she gets minus c Plus v and
if she quits he gets zero.
And here's where our assumptions going
to help us. We've assumed what, what are,
we are still using V as bigger than C,
is that right?
Just like we played in class. So
because of the is bigger than, see
this is going to be the best response.
Again, fighting to of the best response.
All right,
so we know that in fact player
a here has a dominant strategy.
The dominant strategy is
to fight in period one
and this little in this analysis
look, Amen. And Shinsei is fighting.
Not surprisingly, but we're going
to find that B is going to quit.
All right? So, so, uh, bes
best response is to quit.
All right, so here, here is our Nash
equilibrium in this. Okay. All right,
so this,
this,
this game has a Nash equilibrium and he
has one and that equilibrium is fight
one
quick one
and let's just do what it intuitively
you for a second. Intuitively,
if I know I'm fine playing Jake,
and I know that Jake is going
to fight tomorrow and I know,
uh, sorry I'll be around. I know
that Jake's going to quit tomorrow.
I know Jack's going to quit tomorrow
and I'm going to fight tomorrow.
I know that tomorrow I'm going to win.
That prize is there for me tomorrow.
So why would I want to quit
today? Right? I don't, I'm,
I'm going to get a dollar tomorrow,
right? I just fight in this period.
So why would they want to quit
today when it, worst case scenario,
I'm only going to lose 75 cents today.
So I know Jake is quitting tomorrow.
I'm going to stay on and fight
and fight now. And conversely,
if Jake knows he's quitting tomorrow
and she knows I'm going to fight now,
he might as well just quit.
It's what we're learning here
is in this particular example,
in this particular example,
if we know that tomorrow I'm going to win,
I'm gonna win the war, I'm
going to actually going to
win it today. Is that again,
if we know that tomorrow
I'm going to win the war,
I'm actually going to win it today.
All right?
And the converse is true for the case
where I'm the quitter and Jake's the fight
tomorrow. So once again, it's pretty
quick to see that if I'm going to, uh,
uh, from [inaudible] point of
view, if I'm going to fight,
he's gonna want to fight. If I'm going
to quit, he's going to want to fight.
So in either case, he's going to want
to fights. So I'm going to want to quit.
So the NASA could I run
this game is, uh, is quit.
It's quick. One fight to my show.
He can write that in a better
angle. That's probably, again,
quit one
fight too.
All right.
So at this stage we found all of the pure
strategy subgame perfect equilibria in
the game. Let's describe them
before I write them up, right?
One pure strategy,
Nash equilibrium has me fighting in
period one and Jake quitting in period one
and if we got to Paris
to which about we won't,
then I fight again and he quits again.
All right, so let's write that
equilibrium up and we'll do it here.
Uh,
we do it on the top board actually.
Thank you.
So let, let, let, let me get it
right when I write up as that.
There's a whole equilibrium.
So I claim I have now found
all of the pure strategy, yes.
Coffee in this game.
One of them involves my facing in the
first period and facing in the second
period.
I'm Jake quitting in the first period
and quitting in the second period.
And the other one just flips it around.
I quit in the first parade that I got
that I would quit on the second period
and Jake
fights in the first period.
And if he got there,
he would also fight in the second period.
All right?
So these are perfectly natural equilibrium
to think about if you're wanting to
get intuitively one of the,
each of these equilibria
involves a fighter and a quitter.
The Phytel always fights.
The quitter always quits.
If I know I'm playing a quitter,
I'm always going to fight.
So that's the best response.
If I know I'm facing a fighter,
I'm going to want to quit.
So that's the best response.
And those are two very simple
equilibrium, right? That's the good news.
What's the bad news here? The bad
news is we haven't achieved our goal.
Our goal was to argue that rational
players might get involved in a fight and
notice that in each of
these to pure strategy,
subgame perfect equilibria
in each of them,
no real fight occurs.
It's not right.
And each of them,
one person fights the first pro,
but the other person just runs away.
That isn't much of a fight. All right?
Say it again. In each of these
equilibria, one side is willing to fight,
but the other side isn't.
So no fight occurs in a particular,
no costs are incurred in
either of these equilibria,
but I claimed at the beginning I wanted
to explain how we can have costs occur
in equilibrium by Ryan.
Rational players are going to incur costs.
So what are we missing here?
What should I do to try and
find a more costly equilibrium?
I claim I'm still missing
some equilibria here.
What kind of equilibrium I missing? I'm
missing the mixed strategy equilibrium.
So far all we've done is sold out
the pure strategy equilibrium,
but we need to go back and
reanalyze the whole game.
Looking now for mixed strategy,
whatever.
All right,
so we're going to do the entire,
take a deep breath because we won't
take the whole analysis we just did.
We're going to repeat the
entire analysis we just did,
but this time we're going to look at
mixed strategy whenever. All right,
everyone happy what we're doing.
So first of all,
we're going to go back
to the second sub game.
Here's the second sub game and we
already found the pure strategy.
You color breast.
Let me get rid of them
in your notes.
You probably want to rewrite this matrix,
but I'm not going to be ready to here
cause we were a bit short of time.
This is exactly the same
payoff matrix we saw before.
But now I want to look for a mixed
strategy equilibrium in this game.
How do I go about finding
as good review this,
how do I go about finding a mixed
strategy equilibrium in a game like this?
What's the trick for finding
mixed strategy equilibrium?
So we try our guys from New Jersey
and new in New York. My God,
let's try our guys from New Jersey,
New York. How do I, whereas I'm like,
where's my, uh, New York, right?
We will have the true battle here
with him in New York and New Jersey.
How do we find a mixed
strategy equilibrium?
Um, yeah, he's like, ah,
the and q's and set them equal
to one another. That's okay.
Crude thing.
Okay.
So the answer was we find the p's
and q's and quotes sent to them.
Are you called to one another? What is
it? We're actually still equal to what?
What are we saying equal to one?
Let's try and get some response on this.
What does that do it I knew Jersey pie
fleet, whereas I it as the question, yeah,
they fled. Uh, we could give our
texting's and challenge was our tech.
There was a text and down here somewhere.
What does it like I said,
have you called a what?
I guess the chances that one,
that one would fail and yet or that d
one more the other way to fight. Mm,
not quite. Not quite that. The
remark about using and q's as
right, but what does that, this
is a good review for the final,
what is it I'm going to do with those
p's and q's? Yeah, sure. You have it out.
You use the other players, payoffs,
you use the other players. Pay Offs,
an indifferent between the
strategies. Goods. Good.
I'm going to choose,
play a bees mix in such a way as to make
player a indifference between choosing
fight and quits. So as to make
it plausible that be, is it a,
is actually mixing. So again, the
intuition is for a to be mixing.
They must be indifferent
between fighting and quit.
So I'm going to choose the mix
of B to make a indifference.
That's good review. Let's do that.
So here I've used a user that a cue,
but to avoid confusion here,
let me use the letter p.
All right,
we're going to choose P to
make player a indifference.
So if a,
if a fight a fight,
then their payoff is what?
It's all like.
It's minus C with probable OCP.
And can I minus C with Probo,
OCP and VI with problems c one minus p.
All right? Is it just should be coming
back. Now, this is before the midterm,
but you guys were alive
before the midterm, right?
So you were should remember this,
do they fight?
They get minus c times
p Plus v one minus P.
Alright, if they quit, if they quit,
then they get zero with problem OCP and
zero again with probability one minus p.
So we know that if a is mixing,
B must be mixing in such a way as
to make these two numbers equal.
So we know these two must
be equal to one another.
Students that equal, we can
now solve for p. All right,
so what's that going to give us?
It's going to give us v one
minus P is equal to p c.
Okay.
And that I think is p is equal to
v Over v plus six is that right?
I'm just check my order.
And if you remember the game of Hawk
dove that we saw just before the midterm,
the game involving a two, it was
the, it was a game we looked at.
When we look at evolution,
this is essentially the same
game more or less as that game.
And then you'll notice it's the same. How
to make sure we've got here. All right,
so p is equal to v Over v Plus C,
which means one minus P is
equal to c over the bossy.
I'm leaving it up there a bit,
hoping that one of the Tas,
he's going to just do my for me. I
think that's right there. That's right.
All right, so this game is symmetric.
So both players are going to,
we could do the same.
We can do the same for B,
but we'll find the same thing
right to symmetric game. All right,
so the mixed strategy equilibrium,
the mixed Nash equilibrium
in this game has both mix,
both fights with probability
equal to v Over v Plus C.
All right?
Now this is good news because they
were getting some fighting going on,
but we need to do something.
We need to take this Nash
Equilibrium we've just found,
which is a nash equilibrium
in the second sub game.
It's a Nash equilibrium in
the sub game way up here.
And we need to roll back the
payoffs from this sub game.
The equilibrium payoffs in this sub game
into the first stage. That's our method.
How are we going to do that?
Well, if not better, first of all,
figure out what those payoffs are. So
what are the payoffs in this equilibrium?
The payoffs in this
mixed nash equilibrium.
Oh,
what do you want to see?
What the payoffs are going to be if they
post playing this mix while presumably
the payoff from fights and the payoff
and quit must be the same. Is that right?
So we miss,
we'll choose the easier one.
So I claimed that the payoff from quit
is zero times p plus zero times one minus
P, which is zero ve over v
Possy poss zero Cov posse,
but that's equal to
watch zero. Okay, good.
So it's got to be the case
kind of conveniently did.
If they do play this mixed
strategy equilibrium in Stage two,
the payoff they'll get
from playing it is zero.
That's going to make life a little
bit easier later on. All right,
that's our new equilibrium
in the second psalm game.
Now let's roll that
back to the first game.
Okay,
here's our first game again.
Alright.
And everything about this is is correct.
Everything about it is correct
except what's down here.
Let's get rid of what's down here.
Yeah.
Our analysis from before
is more or less than tax.
It's still the case that if
they both quit, they'll get
zero. If they quit fight,
they'll get zero Viavi zero and it's
still the case was they both fight.
They'll both incur costs of c and r both
then get stage two continuation Nash
Payoffs,
is that right?
But now instead of those continuation
Nash Payoffs Being v Zero Zero v,
those continuation Nash Payoffs are going
to be what? They're going to be zero.
They're going to be zero.
So we're going to do here is we're going
to backward and doctor rollback those
zero pay offs and come up
with the corresponding may
to describe the first stage
of the game and heritage is fight,
quit
live,
laugh.
Try and get it right without Jake having
to correct me this time. A little laugh,
middle laugh. It'll cue. This is a,
this is B and the payoffs here,
oh zero zero
zero V v zero just as
before and in this box.
Now we've gotten minus C plus
zero and minus C plus zero.
All right, so it's exactly the
same box we saw before, but now
the continuation payoffs,
how justice zero.
All right, and again, what is this?
This is for the Nash Equilibrium,
as I say, for the mixed, for the mixed
Nash Equilibrium in period two.
All right.
I want, I want to do is I want to find
the mixed equilibrium in parade one,
right? We found the premixed
equipment period two.
Now I want to find the mix
equilibrium and her ed one.
So what I could do here is I could spend
a lot of time, I could put it a piano,
a piano, one minus P and I could
work out what mix of player B.
We'll make a indifference.
I could work at what point mixed of
player hey would make be different.
But does anybody notice
something about this matrix?
What do you notice about this matrix?
Somebody, somebody help me out.
Somebody got to help me out here. Tell
me something about this matrix. W what?
What? What? What's true at this
matrix? The same as the one above.
It's the same as the one above,
right?
The Matrix I just drew when
I rolled back the pay offs,
when I roll back,
the payoffs is exactly the
same matrix that I had here.
It's exactly the same matrix.
So we already know what the mix
strategy you could ever have. Isn't this
the mixed Nash equilibrium in this matrix
is
to fight is is both fight
with probable a c p Equals v over v Posse.
So when now ready,
just show on new,
on new subgame perfect equilibrium.
It's dried it down.
Here's our whole game.
We found the pure group.
Sorry we found a pure spes,
but now we're ready to find the mixed sp.
The mix of getting perfect
equilibrium has player a while.
Before I do that, let me just give this
PNA. Let me call this p p star. Okay,
so Vov Posse,
that's quite Pete star.
So the mix of getting perfect
equilibrium has player one mixing,
fighting with property, pea stone and the
first stage. And then the second stage.
Again, mixing fighting prop with
proper OCP star. This is player one
and player two does
exactly the same thing.
And while we're here,
watch the expected payoff for each player.
If they're playing this mixed
subgame perfect equilibrium,
what does that, it's zero. It's Sarah.
The payoff from this,
the expected payoff
is all right,
so now we're actually getting somewhere.
Now we're really getting somewhere.
Let's just take a deep breath and see
where we are. We, we broke this game down,
this complicated game we played in
class that it conceivably, for example,
when it New York is playing New Jersey
conceivably could go on all night.
Apparently not when the Texans are
playing each other or the football team's
playing the baseball team,
but when we have New York and Jersey,
you could go on all night, hey, we
could tell it to a two period game,
but in a minute, want to go back to the
infinite game, right? In this two period,
gay man,
I tried to argue that we could,
I'm trying to convince you that you
could get fighting occurring Justin
equilibrate with absolutely
standard rational players.
Nothing to do with pride.
It was reputation.
Nothing to do with the fact that these
guys are crazy guys who've drunk the
wharf for Newt New York and New
Jersey. God held them all, right,
you're going to s you can get fighting
with ordinary people in equilibrium.
All right, and what we've shown is
the way which you can get fighting,
is it a mixed strategy equilibrium
in each period of the game.
People fight with pro books.
Eep.
That's just enough fights to give the
other side at an incentive to quit and
just enough problems.
You have the other side quitting
to give the other side of a,
an incentive to fight just exactly enough.
If they play that equilibrium in every
period there's some chance of the game
ending.
But with problems,
the p the game goes
forward to the next period.
So you could potentially have
fights per two prayers by the way.
With what problem? See? Would
there be a fight in both periods?
That's a good homework question.
I won't answer it here. Right?
You can work it out at home.
Alright. Alright. Alright.
So what do we do it here?
Anyone want to tell me that? So, okay.
And what problem we will
probably lose you do.
We're going to fight in the first parade.
A real fight to fight
involving both players.
What do you both players to fights
each a fighting with Bono. Cep.
So the problem is you have both of them.
Fighting is one p squared. All right,
so we're going to fight
in the first period,
the problems he is p squared to
get to fight in both parades.
It's what better Pete Peters,
the fourth. All right?
But we get a fight with probably the
of the fourth going through. All right?
We get fighting and equilibrium.
Moreover,
we get some very intuitive things that
we already learned in the Hawk dove game,
right? The probability
of fights, and they said
the probability of fights occurring,
the problems occurring, it goes, oh,
how's the fee goes up? So the prize gets
bigger. You're more likely to see fights.
The car that seemed right,
and it goes down
and see the problems your fights occurring
goes up in the size of the prize.
That seems intuitively right and
down in the cost of fighting.
All right?
No. Okay, that's reasonable. But
I claimed I could show you this,
not in a two period game,
but in an infinite period game.
So let me spend the last five minutes
taking us to infinite parade games.
All right?
So everybody take a deep breath.
We're now going to come to
something we'd never done before.
We're going to consider a gay
man that could go on forever,
could go on forever.
All right?
And the way we're going to do that
is to use the following idea
and the following picture.
So I can't really draw a true
tree for the infinite period game.
And the reason they can't draw a true
tree for the infinite parade gay man is
one I would run out of shock and
two, I'd run it lunch. Lunchtime.
All right? But you could imagine what
it looks like. It looks like this.
Roughly speaking.
Yes.
Uh hmm.
Can I get this right? It's not.
Again, you can put a period game look,
something like this
and that has again,
all right.
And that goes again.
Okay,
that's so awesome.
All right.
How did it go right the way
through the board and what?
Right the way across whatever street
that is right across campus. All right.
That's what the infinite
tree would look like.
So I clearly can't really
analyze that object,
but what I want to show you is that we
can still solve this game even though
it's an infinite period game.
How are we going to do that?
Let's look at a particular stage.
Let's call the stage
stage 4,503 all right,
whatever that number works right?
For 4,503 whatever it was, right?
So here is the stage,
it's all arbitrary stage,
and then the tree for this
arbitrary stage looks like this.
All right?
And then what I'm going to do is this
is, you know this, this is stage.
What was it? 5,000 was
it 4,503 all right, this,
this is the stage,
all right?
And what I'm going to hide to this is
that before you get into this stage,
you're going to incur some costs,
all right?
And if you go on playing off to
this stage, then you're going to get
continuation values,
all right?
So going into the beginning of the game,
you've incurred some sunk costs,
and if you come out on the
other side and go on playing,
you're going to play some equilibrium
and get continuation values.
But otherwise everything else is the same.
We still have zero zero here.
We still have zero V v here.
We still have visa zero here and here
we still have minus C plus continuation
values and minus c plus continuation.
All right,
and this is something we've seen before,
right?
They said the box is
something we've seen before.
Essentially we've got sunk costs in front,
but they're relevance.
We've got continuation values at the end,
we know how to handle that and we just
put them into the payoffs. All right,
so suppose now suppose that in the
continuation game people play the mixed
strategy that we just found.
Suppose that in the continuation
game people makes with provosts VP,
so they fight with problems. He p Star
and quit with Aldi, one minus p stone,
exposing the continuation game.
They're playing a mixed strategy.
In that case, what is the
continuation value of the game?
Miss that again? All right,
what is it? It's zero, right?
If I'm mixing in the future,
they always had the option to quit.
So it must be that the
continuation value is zero.
So if they mix in the future,
then the continuation value
is zero.
Zero. All right, so now
let's go back to this board.
All right.
To make this board or call
them to the board above,
all they need to do is one thing I need
to add on some sunk costs at the front.
I've got sunk cost at the front.
I'm going to play the game
and then I'm going to get,
isn't it a stage two values? I'm
going to get stage, what was it,
4,503 in all stages in the future.
Values in here and here,
but otherwise it's the same thing and
what's convenient is all of those is zero
anyway,
since they're all zero anyway,
this matrix is still correct,
right?
The continuation values are zero and
zero is another continuation values.
These are the continuation values
and so if I look for a mixed
strategy equilibrium in this game,
it's something I've sold already watched
the mixed strategy equilibrium in this
game.
Anybody?
It's tough. It's exactly what
we found before justice before.
I'm going to mix with
pro se ve over v Posse,
right?
Let's summarize. We did something today
just now that we've never done before.
We've looked at an infinite or these
potentially infinite period game I gained
that could go on forever.
And the way in which we handled the game
that could go on forever was what we
noticed.
Two things.
We noticed that part of the game that
comes before that part of the game that
was passed already, anything that
happened there is just a sunk cost.
It's irrelevant. It's just, I
mean, it hurts. If it's a cost,
it's nice if it's a gain, but it's
sunk. You can't affect it now.
Anything in the future,
anything in the future can
be summarized by the value,
the payoff I'm going to get in the
future by playing the equilibrium in the
future, right? And this
case, the future man mixing,
mixing gave me a value of zero.
So here I am getting a zero in the future
and then I can just analyze the game
in the stage of which I'm in, just as
if it was an ordinary bog, standard,
simultaneous move game.
All right?
When we did,
so in this particular example,
we're going to see more examples
like this after the break.
But in this particular example we
found out something quite surprising.
The thing we found out was in these
war of attrition and settings,
that is an equilibrium with rational
players. Everyone mold, not common
knowledge or rationality.
Everybody's rational. Everyone
knows hypnosis rational.
There are equal ever and which not
only people fights but they could fight
forever in every period they fight
with some policy and we got an extra
prediction out,
a prediction that we weren't expecting
and let me just give you that prediction
and then we'll leave the class with
the hat. The extra prediction is this.
If we look at these wars of attrition
and we keep track all the time in which
the, hang on guys don't know
rusty bags yet. One more thing.
We look at the time at which the Games
have gone on and keep track of the
probability that a war
will end at that time.
So imagine this is, well,
the one you could imagine,
what would one going for one year or
two years or three years or 20 years or
whatever the problem is,
distribution in this war of attrition
is going to look like
this in every period.
The prevalency of continuing
is just p star squared,
so on every period, the chance as
you get further into the future,
there's a greater chance of the war
will end. You can get very long,
very costly wars.
That's the bad news.
The good news is it doesn't
happen very often. All right.
I guess we're all involved in a
rather large and costly war right now,
so I'll leave you that without
pleasant thought over thanksgiving.
Have a good break. Almost.
See you afterwards.